[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: It's possible to
use BigQuery to analyze data
without a credit card by
setting up the BigQuery sandbox
environment.
This video will show you how
to set up your own BigQuery
sandbox.
Start by navigating
to the BigQuery Web UI
at console.cloud.go
ogle.com/bigquery.
Log into your Google account,
or create a new account
if you do not already have one.
If you are logging into Google
Cloud for the first time,
you will need to
choose your country
and accept the terms of service.
Click Agree and Continue.
In order to use the
BigQuery sandbox,
you must create a project.
Enter a project name,
and click Create.
Once the project
is created, you'll
be redirected to
the BigQuery Web UI.
Notice the sandbox
banner indicator
in the upper left-hand
corner of the console.
Congratulations, you
are now ready to start
using the BigQuery sandbox.
You can load or query
data in this project
without an attached
billing account.
Usage will be limited to the
same limits as the free tier,
which can be viewed at
cloud.google.com/free.
Any tables, views, or
partitions and partition tables
automatically expire
after 60 days.
To overcome these
sandbox limits,
you can choose to
upgrade your project
by enabling billing and removing
or updating the expiration
time for your resources.
Happy analyzing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]